welcome to cloud security basics a new
series where we explain the ins and outs
of securing your application on Google
cloud sound London stick around because
in this episode you'll learn about the
first of three distinct areas of cloud
security risk access
[Music]
low cloud detective you showed that you
understand clouds shared security model
but can you solve this what can you do
to stop the wrong people from accessing
your resources for example I could use a
man-in-the-middle attack to intrude on
an existing connection intercepting and
modifying all network traffic between
two devices if I intercepted an admins
traffic I'd even be able to act on your
system with all the privileges of your
admin what can you do to stop that for
your sake I hope you know the answer
okay here's what we know a
man-in-the-middle attack involves an
attacker getting access to cadential
they shouldn't have we could solve this
but there's actually a broader problem
here access access represents ensuring
that only the right identities have
access to the right resources for your
system for example you might not want
developers to be able to leave resources
on your system so you have to enact a
policy or access control to prevent that
from happening by accident or ill will
or you might want to prevent malicious
access exploits like fishing where an
attacker at tricks individuals into
giving out their credentials or denial
of service attacks where an attacker
works to overwhelm a web service to keep
it from functioning properly luckily
Google cloud provides a lot of tools and
services to protect its users some of
those protections include encrypted
traffic and load balancers to combat
man-in-the-middle in DDoS exploits
Universal two-factor authentication to
minimize phishing cloud identity aware
proxy to make sure that only the right
people get access to applications
endpoint management to make sure that
users are using secure devices to access
company resources and more let's see how
they work so how do these tools keep the
wrong people from accessing your system
I know that to combat man in the middle
and DDoS exploits Google cloud encrypts
all internet access at the network level
by default eliminating the concern of a
passive adversary listening for
sensitive information let me show you
how
since TLS requires that servers prove
their identity active man-in-the-middle
attacks are also much more difficult in
google clouds front-end and load
balancers support TLS termination while
providing an entry point to Google's
massive serving resources making a
successful DDoS attack quite challenging
here's how it works
load balancers report information about
incoming traffic to a central DDoS
service if it detects that a DDoS attack
is occurring it can configure the load
balancers to drop or throttle the
traffic Google's central identity
service which users see is the Google
login page ask for a username and
password and assesses risk factors such
as whether users have logged in from the
same device or location in the past the
service issues credentials such as
cookies and OAuth tokens to further
protect users oh and second factors such
as one-time passwords or phishing
resistant security keys can also be used
by users when signing in to help prevent
phishing in fact in order to make
phishing less effective Google pioneered
the u2f tightened security key a
hardware second factor that can be
associated with an account so that log
in is only possible when the second
factor is present the idea being if you
pair something you know like a password
with something you have like a security
key fishing becomes very difficult and
it's easy to set up - once you set these
keys up and change the 2-step
authentication to only use security keys
in the Google admin UI then the next
time a developer logs on after they
enter their password they'll be asked to
touch their security key
hmm how else can we limit unauthorized
access
what about cloud identity aware of proxy
or I AP IA P makes it easy for you to
put up an application on the cloud and
configure a central policy users have to
authenticate against best of all since
IEP is enforced at the network layer
cloud IP requires little to no
application code changes so if you had a
legacy application that was hosted on
premise behind a firewall and wanted to
migrate it to a public endpoint on the
cloud you could drop Cloud IEP in front
of it to acquire authentication
authorization against a Google Group or
G suite domain with little to no changes
to the application at all but that still
leaves a case of what if the laptop
of an admin is compromised by malware
hmm that's where endpoints management
comes in if your platform can be
accessed from your employees own
personal phone or tablet you can use G
suite endpoint management to keep your
company data safe while letting
employees use their favorite personal
device and with endpoints it becomes
easy to do things like set up policies
like on Android devices work apps will
be separated from personal apps or since
Chrome OS is designed for security from
the ground up and doesn't allow the
installation of software only use admin
access
if the admin is using a Chromebook mmm I
figured it out I've got the answer hello
detective I see you've been busy you've
answered my question what can you do to
stop the wrong people from accessing
your data you notice that Google Cloud
could help secure access and
authentication Google Cloud provides
help through identity where proxy
endpoint verification Universal
two-factor and more all of these
features are building up context
associated with the access to make sure
it follows the rules the access should
come from a Chromebook the user should
have proper credentials to login they
should have the required access levels
and they need to have a hardware second
factor in order to get to the particular
API these individual protections layer
on top of each other to help keep your
cloud safer and more secure very good
very good
you've answered today's question but be
ready because next time I want to see
what you can do to keep your data safe
so there you have it another episode of
cloud security basics next episode will
focus on the second of three distinct
areas of cloud security risk data in the
meantime if you want to take a deeper
dive into securing access in the cloud
then check out the article linked in the
description below and stay tuned for the
rest of the cloud security basics series
because when it comes to security you
can't let bad actors win
[Music]